wir kommen jetzt zum nächsten
tagesordnungspunkt da geht es um sofort
zuschlags und das einmal zahlungs gesetz
es gibt einerseits ein
entwurf ein gesetzentwurf der
bundesregierung und zwei anträge der
linken die jetzt hier diskutiert werden
die neue bundesfamilienministerin lisa
paus hat ja schon angekündigt sie möchte
den kinder sofort zuschlag dauerhaft und
lückenlos einführen bis nämlich die
kindergrundsicherung gewährt werden kann
und dieser sofort zuschlag sollen
monatlich 20 euro pro kind
betragen und schon zum ersten juli zum
ersten mal gezeigt werden genaueres wenn
wir jetzt hier in der debatte höheren
erste rednerin ist dagmar schmidt spd
fraktion
ein bisschen hat der lukas köhler von
mir geredet hier
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte damen und herren liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
die menschen in unserem land stehen seit
mehr als zwei jahren vor
herausforderungen und entwicklungen von
denen sie wahrscheinlich nie gedacht
hätten dass es so kommt die controller
pandemie hat alle menschen getroffen
aber sie hat sie unterschiedlich hart
getroffen viele haben schlimme
krankheitsverläufe und tod in den
eigenen familien und freundeskreisen
erlebt viele ihren job verloren oder in
kurzarbeit gearbeiteten viele mussten
ihre kleinen oder auch größeren kinder
durch schulschließung und isolierung
begleiten gerade für diejenigen die
nicht mit guten und sicheren einkommen
ausgestattet waren und sind ist die
belastung immens
und jetzt kommt mit den folgen des
ukraine kriegs noch mehr auf uns zu die
preise steigen nicht nur die
energiepreise sondern mit ihnen viele
andere vor allem jetzt eben auch die
lebensmittelpreise die erwartung an uns
ist dass wir helfen und handeln und das
tun wir mit zunächst zwei großen
entlastungspaket
und wir beschließen heute nicht nur den
sofort zuschlag und die einmalzahlung
sondern auch steuerentlastungen den
kinderbonus und die energiepreis
pauschale insgesamt entlasten wir die
bürgerinnen und bürger mit diesen beiden
paketen um fast 30 milliarden und
wir wollen aber mit unseren markt haben
sich für aktuell helfen sondern wo immer
möglich auch die weichen für die zukunft
stellen und schnell erste schritte in
diese gehen das gilt insbesondere für
den sofort zuschlag für kinder die in
armut aufwachsen die von kinder grund in
die von grundsicherung leben oder deren
eltern wenig verdienen und die deswegen
den kinderzuschlag erhalten für sie
beschließen wir heute einen monatlichen
aufschlag von 20 euro
einmalzahlungen sind wichtige hilfen wo
es aber strukturelle probleme gibt
müssen sie auch strukturell angegangen
werden und deswegen ist diese monatliche
unterstützung für uns auch ein wichtiger
erster schritt hin zu einer
kindergrundsicherung
den kinder sind keine kleinen
arbeitslosen sie können nichts für die
finanzielle situation ihrer eltern
deswegen werden wir eine eigenständige
leistung für kinder schaffen die
automatisch ausgezahlt wird die das
einkommen der eltern berücksichtigt und
bei der anders als bisher diejenigen die
wenig geld haben mehr unterstützung
bekommen als die mit den hohen einkommen
corona die soziale spaltung in bezug auf
die bildungs- und lebenschancen noch
einmal verschärft kinder und jugendliche
haben besonders unter der pandemie
gelitten und sie tun es immer noch
deswegen bleiben wir auch hier nicht bei
einer geldleistung stehen wir nehmen
auch bildung und teilhabe mobilität und
freizeitgestaltung in den blick ein
afrikanisches sprichwort sagt um ein
kind großzuziehen braucht es ein ganzes
dorf und wir lassen die familien eben
nicht allein niemand darf wegen seiner
kinder arm werden und jedes kind in
unserem land muss die gleichen chancen
haben
und wir beschließen eine einmalzahlung
von 200 euro für alle erwachsenen die
grundsicherungsleistungen erhalten und
100 euro für arbeitslose in sgb 3 und
kinder von asylsuchenden die kein
kindergeld erhalten und das ist erst
einmal auch eine gute hilfe gerade die
kleinen einkommen sind besonders stark
von den preissteigerungen betroffen sie
geben anteiliger in ihrem einkommen mehr
in den bereichen aus die eben von der
inflation auch besonders betroffen sind
deswegen müssen wir auch besonders
helfen das tun wir mit der 300 euro
energiekosten pauschale und eben mit der
einmalzahlung von 200 euro für menschen
in der grundsicherung damit sie
entlastet werden aber auch hier brauchen
wir langfristig eine strukturelle
antwort und haben uns deswegen mit dem
bürgergeld viel vorgenommen sofort
zuschlag und einmalzahlungen für die
besonders bedürftigen insgesamt 30
milliarden euro entlastung für die
bürgerinnen und bürger dann
kindergrundsicherung und bürgergeld wir
handeln und das auch weiter tun für
einen sozialstaat auf der höhe der zeit
ich lade sie ein den weg mit uns zu
gehen glück auf
[Applaus]
der kollege kevin trapp bekommt das wort
für die cdu csu fraktion
frau präsidentin werte kolleginnen und
kollegen worum geht es eigentlich heute
im kern auch hier geht es natürlich
wieder um die inflation um die
steigenden preise im land allein über 7
prozent im letzten monat die
bundesregierung rechnet für dieses jahr
mit mehr als 6 prozent
was heißt das ganz konkret auf dem
einkaufszettel der menschen es heißt
dass sie vor einem jahr mit etwas mehr
als zwölf euro
das hier kaufen konnten bananen mehr
käse butter kartoffeln blumenkohl
tomaten brötchen gurken eier und milch
und ein jahr später für den gleichen
betrag können sie heute nur noch das
hier kaufen keine kartoffel mehr kein
blumenkohl mehr keine brötchen mehr
keine gurken keine eier keine milch das
ist die realität mit denen die menschen
konfrontiert sind in diesem land was man
vor einem jahr in vollen tüten an zwei
händen nach hause tragen konnte kann man
jetzt nur noch am kleinen finger in
einer kleinen tüte nach hause tragen und
was machen sie jetzt sie kommen mit
ihrem entlastungspaket daher dessen teil
dazu sofort zuschlag ja auch ist aber
entlastungspaket allein schon der name
finde ich eine zumutung ist es ein
eigentlich nur ein briefumschlag den sie
da überweisen und dann machen sie ein
bisschen hier mit dem neuen euro ticket
zum beispiel wo selbst der grüne
verkehrsminister in baden württemberg
sagt dass die bundesregierung den
ländern jetzt geld wegnimmt für den
öffentlichen personennahverkehr um ihn
in das neun euro ticket zu investieren
dafür können jetzt in baden württemberg
konkret über 100 neue züge im nahverkehr
nicht gekauft werden das ist ihre
politik sie machen
sie machen dort dann ein bisschen trank
rabatt ich sagte ihnen ihr hilfspaket
ist einmalig weil sie nur einmal nicht
hilfen zahlen es ist befristet für ein
wenigen monaten und sie besteuern auch
noch die leistungen die sie den menschen
ums lebens ihnen bilder weg und darüber
hinaus haben sie auch noch die 20
millionen rentnerinnen und rentner
vergessen und liebe frau kollegin
schmidt da reicht es nicht wenn sie
heute morgen im moma magazin dann
einfach sagen wir pech gehabt wir hätten
es auch gerne anders gehabt aber es ging
nicht sie haben da konkret versagt
und jetzt kommen sie mit dem sofort
zuschlag um einen kinderzuschlag dem
grunde nach wichtig weil wir das als
große koalition letztes jahr auch schon
gemacht haben aber sie schaffen es noch
nicht einmal die inflation auszugleichen
das wurde in der anhörung deutlich 30
euro zu wenig beim kinderzuschlag 130
euro zu wenig beim sofort zuschlag das
160 euro oder wie man jetzt neuerdings
feststellt so viel wie einen privatflug
im hebel von hier nach sylt liebe
freunde so geht das nicht und da muss
ich mich schon fragen sie haben ihren
bazooka finanzminister zum kanzler
gemacht wo bleibt die bazooka jetzt dass
es kein bus mehr das ist maximal ein
rohrkrepierer den sie hier vorleben und
bevor sie sich so aufregen das denn
nicht nur die worte der cdu csu fraktion
das hat sogar der vdk in seiner
stellungnahme gesagt zitat dieses gesetz
ist ein chaotischer flickenteppich und
deshalb fordern wir als union heute noch
einmal einen echten schutzschirm gegen
inflation sie müssen die kalte
progression vollständig bekämpfen sie
müssen die steuern auf energie
vollständig senken und sie könnten auch
endlich mal darüber nachdenken eine gute
idee der großen koalition noch mal
anzuwenden nämlich die steuersenkungen
der mehrwertsteuer weil die gerade auch
den geringverdienern massive entlassen
geben kann denn es darf nicht sein dass
lidl luxus wird vielen dank
kaka war das für die unionsfraktion zum
gesetzentwurf der bundesregierung und
zwei anträge der linksfraktion zum thema
unter anderen kinder sofort zuschlag
nächster redner es andreas dresch
bündnis 90 die grünen sehr geehrte damen
und herren wir haben hier in diesem haus
schon einige male über das thema
steigende preise energiepreise
lebensmittelpreise gesprochen und das
passiert immer das gleiche die kollegen
von der union fordern senkung von allem
steuersenkungen in allen bereichen und
dann passiert was sehr interessante ist
wenn man sich die anträge bei ihnen
anguckt dann sieht man dass ihre
haushälterin jedes mal rein schreiben
alles unter haushaltsvorbehalt weil sie
nicht finanziert haben weil sie
keinerlei ahnung haben wie sie das
umsetzen wollen weil es nichts mehr sind
einer seriösen finanzpolitik zu tun hat
und weil sie sei zentraler position
haben vergessen haben wie man politik
macht das was die flickenteppich nennen
heißt dass wir ganz konkret menschen die
es brauchen geld zukommen lassen und
dass wir es auch noch finanzieren das
geld kommt an und das ist der
unterschied
und ganz konkret bedeutet das dass wir
als ganz unbürokratische hilfe 200 euro
für alle erwachsene in der
grundsicherung zeit im juli zahlen im
juli kommt das anderen ist das geld auf
dem konto und dann haben die leute das
gleichzeitig zahlen wir 100 euro für
kinder über das kindergeld und wir haben
dabei auch die kinder die nicht im
kindergeld sind nicht vergessen auch
kinder im asylbewerberleistungsgesetz
die willkommen genauso 100 euro weil wir
klar sind an der stelle es gibt nicht
kinder erster und zweiter klasse wir
selbst uns als ampel ein für alle kinder
in deutschland und haben alle kinder
gleichermaßen im blick
und das was wir tun das ist nur der
vorbote viel größere reformen wir haben
längst mit der arbeit begonnen an der
kindergrundsicherung wir werden
vereinfachen wir werden systematisieren
wir werden entbürokratisieren und wir
werden das kindliche existenzminimum
ganz neu berechnen das braucht ein
bisschen weil wir das anständig und
ernsthaft machen aber wir sind längst
dran das gleiche gilt für das bürgergeld
auch da sind werden der arbeit wir
werden dafür sorgen dass wir das neu
strukturieren und wir werden
gleichzeitig dafür sorgen dass wir
menschen das zukommen lassen was sie
dauerhaft brauchen um in dieser
gesellschaft teilzuhaben wir machen
jetzt akute hilfe und wir planen die
großen reformen die dann von der ampel
auf den weg gebracht werden
ich will zum zweiten wichtigen punkt in
diesem gesetz kommen millionen menschen
müssen fliehen weil putin mit einem
barbarischen angriffskrieg die ukraine
überfallen hat und mit diesem gesetz tun
wir etwas was in deutschland noch nie
davor getan wurde wir ermöglichen
millionen von menschen wenn sie zu uns
kommen die möglichkeit ganz direkt in
unsere sozialsysteme zukommt so ein
riesen unterschied zu allem was davor da
gewesen ist und wir machen gleichzeitig
bei der wohnsitz auflage die dinge so
und wir verändern sie so dass menschen
hier tatsächlich in der arbeit finden
können egal wo das in deutschland ist
die die arbeiten wollen kriegen die
chance wir wollen dass menschen teil
dieser gesellschaft werden können wir
wollen menschen der echte chance geben
und so eine zukunfts gewandtheit und so
eine ernsthaftigkeit in dieser debatte
die hat es bislang in deutschland von
einer bundesregierung noch nicht gegeben
meine damen und meine herren
wirtschaften heute beides wir schaffen
entlastung für die menschen in
deutschland die hier leben die das
brauchen für genau die die es am meisten
brauchen und gleichzeitig machen wir
etwas was neu ist wir schaffen eine
perspektive die gleichzeitig bedeutet
dass die menschen die zu uns kommen auch
im arbeitsmarkt in allem was wir in der
zukunft hier brauchen da und ihnen jobs
wo wir unterstützung brauchen ankommen
und wir werden wenn wir das so machen in
zukunft wir werden in zukunft wir als
deutsche werden davon profitieren und
das ist das was auch die botschaft heute
ist wir nehmen die fragen an und wir
wenden sie so dass ihr am ende gut für
uns und für das land insgesamt wird
dankeschön
andreas autos sagt dass hier eine
leistung geschaffen wird für diejenigen
die es am meisten brauchen und es sind
2,9 millionen kindern die von diesem
sofort zuschlag der hier diskutiert wird
profitieren sollen ab ersten juli der
tour ihr spricht jetzt für die fdp
fraktion
sowie das tut mir leid die nächste
rednerin gefolgt
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin meine
damen und herren als ich letzte woche
hier zu diesem gesetz gesprochen habe
hatte sie darauf hingewiesen dass mehr
als jeder fünfte in deutschland arm ist
und schon deshalb halten wir die
einmalzahlungen zahlungen für die
inflations geplagten abend für richtig
und auch den zuschlag für die kinder
heute präsentiert sich das gesetz aber
ganz anders denn ihm wurde ein richtiger
hammer hinzugefügt wie sofortige
aufnahme aller ukraine flüchtlinge in
hartz iv
das bedeutet dann 1000 euro mehr im jahr
für jeden flüchtling nicht einmalig
sondern dauerhaft
mit der rechten hand teilte staat also
einmalig ein almosen an die schon länger
hier leben den armen tauss mit der
linken nach vergibt er gleichzeitig ein
dauerhaftes geschenk an die ukraine für
sie sind die traditionellen
asylbewerberleistungen nicht mehr gut
genug
begründet wird das mit der besseren
integration in den arbeitsmarkt über die
jobcenter tatsächlich kommen aber in
erster linie alte und mütter mit kindern
wenn die wirkliche arbeiten wollen
werden jede menge
zusätzliche kita und kindergartenplätze
gebraucht genügend betreuungskräfte gibt
es schon heute nicht vor unsere
asylbewerber referenten auch nicht mit
den asylbewerbern leistungsgesetz oder
wollen sie das behaupten dummes zeug
[Applaus]
wenn sie vermutete sorgen so kannst du
[Musik]
eine kostenschätzung für dieses geschenk
liegt seitens der regierung nicht vor
stand heute wissen wir dass knapp
600.000 ukraine flüchtlinge bei uns im
land sind es könnten aber auch deutlich
mehr sein der das musste sich nur
registrieren wer sich registrieren
lassen wollte sie sollen jetzt alle
hartz iv leistungen erhalten wie ein
deutscher bürger der 20 jahre gearbeitet
hat dann ein jahr arbeitslos würde und
der einen großen anteil seiner hartz iv
leistungen selbst erarbeitet hat wollen
sie das bestreiten
und bekommt noch nicht mehr als jeder
neue ukraine flüchtling ist denn das
tier
und wenn der ukrainer kinder hat bekommt
er selbstverständlich auch kindergeld
sogar wenn er gar nicht im land ist das
nennt man anwesenheits fiktion denn
seine anwesenheit wird nicht überprüft
so jedenfalls die bundesanstalt für
arbeit
ja hallo keine flüchtlinge gekommen dann
auch automatisch in die gesetzliche
krankenversicherung die chronisch
unterfinanziert ist denn der staat zahlt
viel zu niedrig an trust
krankenkassenbeiträge für die hartz 4
empfänger sie denken nicht einmal die
hälfte der tatsächlich anfallenden
leistungen das gesamte defizit beträgt
zehn milliarden euro im jahr und raten
sie mal wer dafür aufkommt der
beitragszahler seit jahren finanzierte
einen teil der hartz 4 kranken
leistungen mit wurde aber nie dazu
gefragt und dazu passt natürlich ins
bild dass minister lauterbach noch für
dieses jahr weitere beitragserhöhung
vorausgesagt hat und dieses eine mal
wird minister lauterbach wohl recht
behalten
jetzt war ich auch mal eine voraussage
unsere gerechtigkeitsfanatiker an der
ampel werden sicherlich nicht lange
hinnehmen dass es hier zwei klassen von
flüchtlingen gibt die alten wird die
guten leistungen und die ukraine
flüchtlinge mit den richtig guten
leistungen ist ja irgendwie rassistisch
geht ja gar nicht
daher werden sie noch in dieser
legislaturperiode ein weiteres gesetz
hier einbringen weg mit dem
asylbewerberleistungsgesetz her mit
hartz iv alle die zu uns kommen geld
spielt keine rolle
das wäre dann der endgültige ausverkauf
unseres sozialsystems aber schon das
heutige gesetz stellt natürlich einen
klassischen pull faktor vier neue
flüchtlinge da erst recht wenn dieses
land dann nach jahrelangem krieg also
die keine nach jahrelangem tief
außenministerin werbeflut ihn besiegen
komplett zerstört am boden liegt dieses
im nato-rat auch andere länder haben
liegen sie kommen bitte die arena satz
zum beispiel die usa den anführer
unserer westlichen wertegemeinschaft der
cornelius solche lokale flüchtlinge ins
land die einen bürgen für ihre kosten
dafür liegen
und trägt komm bitte zu hängen und am
tag besser in deutschland da geht es
leichter
dagegen
der kollege jens martin hat das wort für
die fdp-fraktion und jetzt verträge ist
sprecher für bürgergeld seiner fraktion
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen eine anmerkung
nur zur afg anstatt hier rum zu nörgeln
dass wir solidarisch sind mit den
ukrainischen geflüchteten sollten sie
stattdessen mit ihrem putin freundin
denisa fraktionen reden denn der ist
verantwortlich für die ukrainischen
geflüchtete frau nicht um sowohl
antworten wie david und
im gesetz und dazu möchte ich jetzt viel
mehr kommen es geht darum dass in
deutschland 1,7 millionen kinder und
jugendliche in haushalten aufwachsen
die nach sgb zwar eine grundsicherung
empfangen umgangssprachlich besser
bekannt als hartz 4 1,7 millionen kinder
und jugendliche für diese kinder und
jugendlichen bedeutet das für ihre
chancen im leben für ihre
zukunftsperspektiven
dass zwei tatsachen besonders
demotivierend sind und die erste
tatsache ist dass laut einer studie in
deutschland ist bis zu sechs
generationen dauert bis nachkommen einer
familie sich von einem niedrigem bis zum
mittleren einkommen hocharbeiten können
sechs generationen hinterm ocd
durchschnitt in den skandinavischen
ländern sind das zwei generationen der
traum vom aufstieg durch leistung ist
häufig nur eine seifenblase in
deutschland und die zweite tatsache die
diese 1,7 millionen jungen menschen sgb
2 bezug besonders zu motivieren ist dass
der bildungserfolg
maßgeblich in deutschland im
internationalen vergleich vom
bildungsgrad der eltern immer noch viel
zu stark abhängt und wenn es eine
schnittmenge gibt die ich finde bei den
sgb 2 b 10 zwischen geringe
qualifikationen geringer bildungsgrad
und sgb 2 beziehung dann bedeutet das
für diese kinder und jugendlichen eine
falle nämlich das für sie es bedeutet
dass sozialer aufstieg viel zu häufig
ein traum bleiben dass ihre biografie im
sozialstaat feststecken bleibt weil
soziale aufstieg durch bildung nicht
möglich ist und dass die abhängigkeit
von sozialleistungen viel zu häufig
weiter verehrt wird und hinzu kommt dann
eine weitere studie das institut für
arbeitsmarkt und berufsforschung das
ergeben hat dass beim familie die kinder
haben und es gebe zwei bezug sind ist es
doppelt so unwahrscheinlich dass die den
sgb 2 bezug verlassen also wenn ich
keine kinder habe ist es doppelt so
wahrscheinlich dass ich selbst aus sgb 2
reinkomme kinder sind also auch noch
eine chance ganze für die erwachsenen
sich selbst aus dem leistungsbezug
herauszuarbeiten und dann und dann kam
die pandemie dazu und hat für diese
jungen menschen für die 1,7 millionen
jungen menschen sgb 2 bezug noch dazu
geführt dass die schwierigkeit haben
ausbildungsplatz zu finden war die
ausbildungsverträge zurückgegangen sind
dann dann hat die caritas noch erforscht
dass die das dritte kind psychisch an
fertig ist und das bildungs
ungerechtigkeiten verschärft haben und
deswegen handeln wir jetzt an der ampel
auch für diese 1,7 millionen menschen
für kinder und jugendliche für die
entscheidet nämlich diese die
preissteigerung die jetzt noch hinzu
kommt zu den verschärfungen der pandemie
zu den chancen ungerechtigkeiten die ich
vorher ausschauen hatte das gewicht der
brotdose in der schulpause es
entscheidet darüber ob ich in den sommer
in den sommerferien ins freibad gehen
kann und ausflug machen kann ist
entscheidet darüber ob ich es schaffe
mich raus zu arbeiten oder nicht und die
möglichkeit von sozialer teilhabe hat
und ja
für einige ist 200 euro mehr oder
weniger lapidar für einige sind 20 euro
kinderbonus nicht erwähnenswert für
einige sind 100 euro die noch mal ein
sofort zuschlag dass wir zwei
tagesordnungspunkte weiter behandeln
nicht entscheidend für eine zweiköpfige
familie ein paar was noch zwei kinder
hat bedeutet aber dieses
entlastungspaket was wir jetzt
beschließen und in den nächsten zwei
tagesordnungspunkte
100 euro einmalzahlung und jeden monaten
nochmal 40 euro zusätzlich für die
bedeutet das zeitzeichen ja oder nein
und ich weiß dass wir das sind keine
großen sprünge die möglich sind bei den
aktuellen zeit steigerungen aber es ist
trotzdem ein beweis dass diese ampel
auch zeigt dass wir genau diese jungen
menschen im blick nehmen und es ist auch
weiter wichtig dass wir das machen und
wir werden und das ist eine brücke zur
kindergrundsicherung etwas machen was
sie nicht gemacht haben das haben wir
heute ausschauen gemacht nämlich die
bafög reform angestoßen das haben sie in
der pandemie nicht gemacht und dann eine
kindergrundsicherung ein für die 1,7 wir
werden die bildungs- und teilhabepaketes
reformieren dass nicht nur 30 prozent
von nachhilfeunterricht sportverein bei
kindern und jugendlichen ankommen
sondern dass ich durch eine digitale
chancen portal 100 prozent abrufen kann
und das ist der unterschied wir sind
bereit zu informieren sie halten hier
reden in der opposition die nicht mit
ihrem regierungshandeln in einklang
bringen und hätten sie eine dritte hand
gehabt dann hätten sie sich selbst
gefilmt und das 1 x 1 mm hochgeladen ich
freue mich auf die weitere debatte oder
auf den beschluss
die linksfraktion hat hier in dieser
debatte zwei anträge eingereicht in
einem fordert sie den regelsatz in neu
zu berechnen und in einem anderen in
denen kinder sofort zuschlag um den es
jetzt geht
zu erhöhen auf 100 euro monatlich und
für die den gespräche jetzt in jessica
tati
schlägt einmalzahlungen für erwachsene
im sozialleistungsbezug vor einmal höhe
von 100 euro für corona mehrbedarfe und
weitere 100 euro wegen der hohen
inflation bei strom und lebensmitteln
und das ist völlig unzureichend
sie sind alleine schon deshalb
unzureichend weil sie nicht einmal den
aktuellen massiven inflations
inflationsrate ausgleichen das hat ihn
nicht nur die linke sondern das haben
ihnen bei der anhörung hier im bundestag
die wohlfahrts und sozialverbände in
allergrößter einigkeit bestätigt
diakonie paritätischer familienbund der
katholiken zukunftsforum familie alle
sagen die einmalzahlungen sind viel zu
niedrig sie sind zwar besser als nichts
ok sie tauchen aber nur für eine kurze
übergangslösung auch der dgb hat klipp
und klar gemacht ich zitiere wir
brauchen einen dauerhaften zuschlag die
regelsätze müssen grundlegend neu
ermittelt werden und deutlich angehoben
werden damit sie einen wirksamen schutz
vor armut bieten zitat ende das
unterstreichen alle einheiten sind und
die die lebenssituation von menschen in
hartz4 gut kennen hören sie auf diese
leute
die seit jahren klein berechneten
regelsätze lassen sich nicht mit ihren
luftigen einmalzahlungen reparieren
geben sie sich einen ruck der rechnen
sie die regelsätze jetzt neu ohne
tricksereien die linke linke hat das
gemacht inklusive eines
inflationsausgleichs muss der regelsatz
auf ehrliche
687 euro erhöht werden so sieht respekt
aus
die leistung nicht ausreichen dass sich
die menschen nicht tag und nacht sorge
um ihre existenz machen müssen wenn sie
brauchen doch all ihre kraft für die
arbeit zu werden oder für eine
weiterbildung das ziel muss es doch sein
dass die leute raus aus hartz 4 kommen
dass sie von ihrer arbeit leben können
und nicht sie in armut zu halten herr
minister
erhöhen sie die regelsätze verdammt noch
mal
der bundesminister für arbeit und
soziales hubertus heil wurde hier eben
schon angesprochen und er ist auch der
nächste redner hier in dieser debatte
wird sich wahrscheinlich eher zum
gesetzentwurf der bundesregierung als zu
den anträgen der linksfraktion aussagen
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen wir entlasten
mit dem gesamten paket im umfang von 30
milliarden euro arbeitnehmerinnen und
arbeitnehmer wir helfen menschen in der
grundsicherung deren familien während
kindern übrigens auch rentnerinnen und
rentner dass viel drin in diesem
gesamtpaket aber eines will ich auch
deutlich sagen mit diesem hause sehr
dankbar dass wir es heute auch
ermöglichen in doppelter hinsicht
solidarität zügen gegenüber menschen die
bedürftig sind in unserem land gerade in
diesen zeiten von preissteigerung aber
auch gegenüber geflüchteten menschen die
nicht aufgrund eines pulvers zu uns
gekommen sind frau kollegin von der afd
sondern weil sie vor putins furchtbaren
krieg zu uns gekommen und ich sage ihnen
eins der deutlich
unabhängig davon dass ihre rede von
fachlichkeit nicht geprägt war es geht
nämlich um die gleichstellung von
menschen jetzt geflüchtete zu uns
gekommen sind über den übergang in die
grundsicherung systeme mit anerkannten
da sind aber das ist der sachlich hinter
gut aber dass eine partei die hier in
größeren teilen die propaganda mäßig
fünfte kolonne moskaus ist hier
geflüchtete menschen
die ja geflüchtete menschen gegen
bedürftige menschen aus spielt wie
sollte sich schämen und sich an dieser
debatte wird zu haben
und ich sage ihnen an dieser stelle
diese bundesregierung wird nicht
zulassen denn es geht um doppelte
solidarität dass in diesen schwierigen
zeiten menschen die hilfe in deutschland
brauchen einheimische menschen die
bedürftig sind gegen geflüchtete
ausgespielt werde und es geht auch um
eine vernünftige frage an dieser stelle
nämlich wie kriegen wir es hin dass die
geflüchteten menschen bei uns in
deutschland aus einer hand durch die
jobcenter wird wort werden übrigens auch
eine frage der solidarität liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen mit den ländern
und kommunen denn der bund lässt mit
diesem rechtskreis wechsel die kommunen
eben nicht in dieser zeit im regen
stehen es ist eine nationale
kraftanstrengung sich vernünftig und
anständig um die geflüchteten menschen
zu kümmern ja wir verbessern ihren
krankenversicherungsschutz das ist auch
richtig so und wir sorgen dafür dass sie
eine perspektive aus dem deutschen
arbeitsrecht
ich sage ihnen ist es vernünftig dass
wir in diesen zeiten solidarität
organisieren dass wir hatten abfedern
für die menschen die von
preissteigerungen betroffen sind dass
wir auf der anderen seite dafür sorgen
dass europa und deutschland auch seiner
nachbarschaftlichen pflicht gerecht wird
anständig mit geflüchteten menschen
umzugehen und ich sage ihnen auch wir
haben gehandelt wir haben dafür gesorgt
in europa anders als in anderen krisen
dass die menschen allen europäischen
mitgliedsstaaten einen schutzstatus
bekommen aber sie durchlaufen eben kein
asyl verfahren durch diesen status sie
geben nie auf dem
asylbewerberleistungsgesetz raus auch
das wissen sie nicht und deshalb ist es
richtig dass wir jetzt diesen übergang
in die grundsicherungssystem
organisieren dass der berufsanerkennung
voran bringt das für kinderbetreuung
organisieren dass wir den zugang zum
arbeitsmarkt nicht nur rechtlich sondern
praktisch ermöglichen das sei an dieser
stelle doch diese schule zu nehmen
und zu all den ich meine union schuldig
bitte ich durfte in der letzten
legislaturperiode mit dieser fraktion
zusammen arbeiten wir haben durchaus
sozialen fortschritt an der ein oder
andere stelle hinbekommen aber ich kann
mich erinnert bei jeder verbesserungen
im sozialen bereich musste meine spd
fraktion das hart gegen die cdu
erkämpfen das war bei der grundrente so
das war beihilfen für
grundsicherungsbeziehern willst du hier
so jedes mal zwar beim mindestlohn so
und jetzt in der opposition sich
hinzustellen und mehr mehr mehr zu
fordern ich finde dann sollte man mit
einem nazi vergangenheit zu diesem auto
und deshalb an dieser stelle ein klares
bekenntnis dieser entlastungspaket in
die wir jetzt auf den weg bringen helfen
konkret den menschen in einer
schwierigen lebenssituation wenn
preissteigerung länger anhalten sind
dann werden wir auch strukturell weiter
entlasten wird auf dem weg des
bürgergeldes zu diskutieren sein das
betrifft auch anders was wir für
arbeitnehmer und arbeitnehmer auf den
weg bringt übrigens wichtig dass der
mindestlohn am ersten oktober auf 12
euro steigt auch dafür werden als
positionen bleiben
und damit beweist übrigens diese
koalition in schwierigen zeiten können
sich die menschen in diesem land auf den
sozialstaat verlassen das ist unsere
politik was ihre herzlichen dank
bundesarbeitsminister robertos heil hat
hierfür den gesetzentwurf geworben nach
der debatte werden wir abgeordneten
darüber und über die anträge der linken
ja auch abstimmen nächste rednerin ist
ihr kleid für die unionsfraktion sehr
geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
mehr als 600.000 ukrainerinnen und
ukrainer sind seit beginn von putins
angriffskrieg zu uns gekommen sie
fliehen vor bomben sie fliehen vor leid
sie fliehen vor schrecken sie kommen ein
für sie fremdes land und das erste was
sie sehen und erleben in deutschland ist
die große hilfsbereitschaft der vielen
ehrenamtlichen
egal ob an den bahnhöfen oder in den
auftrag aufnahme einrichtungen überall
engagieren sich die menschen in unserem
land dafür danke ich dafür danken wir
als cdu csu bundestagsfraktion ihnen von
herzen
die ehrenamtlichen helfer leisten einen
unschätzbaren beitrag und auch die
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter in den
behörden zeigen großartigen einsatz und
es ist richtig dass der bund sich hier
stärker beteiligt als
cdu/csu-bundestagsfraktion begrüßen wir
ausdrücklich den beschluss der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz wir
begrüßen das ukrainische
kriegsflüchtlinge leistungen nach
sozialgesetzbuch erhalten wir begrüßen
das ukrainische kriegsflüchtlinge einen
einfacheren zugang zum arbeitsmarkt
bekommen
mit blick auf den gesetzentwurf der
ampel koalition zum rechtskreis wechsel
ist aber auch festzustellen gut gemeint
ist noch lange nicht gut gemacht viele
fangen sind hier noch offen insbesondere
mit blick auf die umsetzung und genau
deshalb haben wir einen
entschließungsantrag eingebracht um
fehler beim sogenannten rechtskreis
wechsel zu vermeiden
das gesetz schafft in seiner derzeitigen
fassung unnötigen bürokratischen
mehraufwand für menschen die gerade erst
vor krieg geflohen sind und wir haben
die ganz große sorge dass durch den
übergang in die grundsicherung systeme
von 600.000 menschen innerhalb kürzester
zeit ein enormer verwaltungsaufwand
entsteht wir haben auch große sorge dass
sich die wohnsituation viele geflüchtete
aufgrund des übergangs ins sgb 2
ungewiss werden könnte und auch eine
gerechte verteilung ist nach derzeitigem
stand nicht gegeben deshalb erwarten wir
von der bundesregierung dass sowohl
geflüchtete als auch kommunen und länder
mit dem rechtskreis wechsel nicht
überfordert werden wir erwarten vom bund
dass die technischen und die rechtlichen
voraussetzungen für die datenmigration
geschaffen werden hier braucht es
deutlich mehr unterstützung vom bund die
zuständigen und
nicht nur hierher bundesminister sie
haben es angesprochen die
kinderbetreuung ich kannte konnte dazu
jetzt nichts in dem gesetzentwurf finden
deswegen hier nochmal mein appell bitte
vergessen sie die kinderbetreuung und
die schulen nicht denn die die zu uns
kommen sind zum großteil frauen und
kinder und auch hier dürfen länder und
kommunen nicht alleine gelassen werden
probieren sie funktionen bietet ich
komme sehr gerne zum schluss in der
jetzigen situation kommt es vor allen
dingen auf schnelle und unbürokratische
hilfe an und da würde ich mir wünschen
dass die bundesregierung sich vielleicht
bei den helferinnen und helfer die
schnelle tore könnten helfen ein
beispiel den vielen dank
linda heitmann hat das wort für benutzt
man stück
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin meine damen und herren
eine krebskranke frau flieht aus der
ukraine
wochenlang muss in berlin auf behandlung
warten ihr schicksal ist kein einzelfall
so beginnt diese woche eine reportage
auf zeit online
sie könnte aktueller nicht sein und ich
bin sehr froh dass wir hier jetzt
handeln und dass wir heute mit diesem
rechtskreis wechsel wirklich konkrete
verbesserungen beschließen für
ukrainische geflüchtete zum beispiel mit
krebs mit tuberkulose mit hepatitis mit
hiv oder mit anspruch auf eine
substitutionstherapie das sind menschen
die wirklich dauerhaft anspruch auf eine
gute medizinische versorgung haben auf
diese angewiesen sind und die müssen wir
ihnen in diesem lande auch bieten können
meine damen und herren als gesellschaft
haben wir mittlerweile erfahrung damit
vor gewalt und krieg geflüchtete hier in
unserem land zu integrieren und auch
angemessen zu versorgen aber die
menschen die jetzt zu uns kommen die
unterscheiden sich von den geflüchteten
die die vergangenen jahre gekommen sind
ja es sind frauen es sind kinder es sind
aber auch viele alte menschen es sind
menschen mit behinderung es sind weisen
die hier nach deutschland fliehen vor
diesem schrecklichen krieg und gerade
diese menschen haben doch das recht auf
eine kontinuierliche gesundheitliche und
auch pflegerische versorgung nicht nur
in notfällen sondern dauerhaft das ist
dringender denn je und wir setzen hier
heute mit diesem mpk beschluss um das
die geflüchteten aus der ukraine ab dem
ersten juni wirklich nicht nur anspruch
auf grundsicherung haben sondern auch
auf eine vernünftige
gesundheitsversorgung die durch die
krankenkassen finanziert wird
ich muss sagen ich bin sehr froh über
das schnelle und politisch auch breit
getragene handeln was hier an den tag
legen ich möchte aber dass wir nicht
stehen bleiben das nächste projekt was
wir jetzt angehen müssen ist auch das
projekt aus dem koalitionsvertrag
sprachmittler als gesetzlichen anspruch
ins spd fünf zu bringen denn nur wer
sich beim arzt verständlich machen kann
und wer versteht was ihm erzählt wird
der kann auch vernünftig und adäquat
behandelt werden ich fühle mich daher
sehr dass die ampel hier beschlüsse
fasst dass wir in diesem punkt voran
kommen hat man uns dass wir hier
wirklich eine gute gesundheitsversorgung
für alle schaffen vielen dank
linda heitmann war das für bündnis 90
die grünen wurde wie aber auch schön
viele rednerinnen und redner vorher an
ihre zeit erinnert und hardy rieck von
der linksfraktion hat nun genau eine
minute redezeit
präsidentin liebe kolleginnen butter
kostet gerade drei euro butter 3 euro
nur ein beispiel für lebensmittelpreise
die durch die decke gehen in deutschland
wächst bereits jetzt jedes fünfte kind
in armut auf für diese familien ist die
inflation einen grund zur panik ein
kinder sofort zuschlag der auch was
bringt es also zwingend notwendig und
sozialverbände sagen klar dass kinder
bei der berechnung der sozialleistungen
78 euro vorenthalten werden das war
schon vor corona so und das
auszugleichen wäre doch das absolute
minimum was ein kinderzuschlag reichten
hinzu kommt nun seit monaten mehrbedarf
und reis explosionen 100 euro fordern
wir deswegen rückwirkend zum januar das
wäre ein erster schritt im kampf gegen
den namen aber wofür plötzlich die ampel
jetzt ja auch die schulter für 20 euro
ist es ihr ernst ich zitiere minister
heil 20 euro das klingt für viele
menschen vor allen dingen auch hier im
bundestag die viel mehr verdient
ziemlich wenig es ist ziemlich wenig
aber netter versuch
der habsburger und mal ehrlich wenn 20
euro ab juli wirklich ihr großer wurf
zur bekämpfung der kinderarmut ist dann
wünsche ich ihnen allen dass sie niemals
arm werden und auf eine regierung wie
diese hier angewiesen sind
sobald also hd reicheneck kinder und
jugendpolitische sprecherin der
linksfraktion und auf sie folgte rasch
in aßlar für die spd-fraktion sie sitzt
im ausschuss für arbeit und soziales und
hier gab es
geburtstagswünsche rasch an dass herr
hat heute geburtstag
vielen dank für den glückwunsch der
geehrte frau präsidentin meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren werte
kolleginnen und kollegen diese koalition
hat sich auf den weg gemacht unsere
gesellschaft in ihrer vielfalt zu
respektieren und allen menschen die
hilfe brauchen auch wirklich zu helfen
ich habe in den jahren 2016 17 erst als
asyl koordinatorin später als
integrationsbeauftragte im sächsischen
freiberg gearbeitet
ich durfte in der zeit asylsuchende auf
ihrem weg in ein neues leben bei uns
hier in deutschland begleiten und
glauben sie mir das baden nicht immer
einfach vor allem für die nur die zu uns
geflüchtet sind in einem fremden land
anzukommen eine fremde sprache zu lernen
erst mal nicht arbeiten zu dürfen mit
völlig fremden menschen in einer
erstaufnahmeeinrichtung ohne
privatsphäre zu wohnen das ist alles
kein zuckerschlecken und glauben sie mir
niemand auch wirklich niemand sucht sich
das freiwillig aus denn eine flucht ist
niemals zweifel ist
ich hoffe inständig dass niemanden von
uns je so eine situation erreicht denn
wir tun ja gerne so als sei das alles
ganz weit weg hätte das alles nichts mit
uns zu tun und jetzt merken wir dieser
tage aber sehr schmerzlich wie nahe so
eine situation auf einmal doch sein kann
und deshalb ist mir das folgende
besonders wichtig menschen im
asylbewerberleistungsgesetz sind keine
nummer im system sie sind menschen die
haben harte schicksale hinter sich und
sind teil schwer traumatisiert sie haben
ihr zuhause ihre familie und freund
verloren sie haben dinge erlebt und
gesehen die sie nie wieder los werden
sie haben kinder zuerst gelernt haben
was krieg und tod bedeuten bevor sie
gelernt haben was es überhaupt heißt zu
leben asylsuchende sind menschen wie sie
und ich und sie haben unseren respekt
verdient
mit der heutigen lesung des sofort
zuschlag sind einmalzahlungen gesetze
nehmen will sie endlich auf die über
380.000 menschen die bei uns in
deutschland leistungen nach dem
asylbewerberleistungsgesetz
beziehen das war nicht einfach und
deswegen möchte ich an dieser stelle
meinen kollegen martin rosemann und
einfach an annika klose danken die dafür
gesorgt haben dass dieser personenkreis
jetzt im vorliegenden gesetz bedacht
wird vielen dank dafür denn
für die menschen im leistungsbezug dass
das ein unglaublicher gewinn 200 euro
bedeuten gerade hier eine kleine welt
und jeden monat 20 euro zusätzlich für
die kinder das mag wenig klingen wir
haben es gerade wieder gehört das kann
aber sehr viel bewirken denn es kann
genau dieses eine zusätzliche spielzeug
sein mit dem ein kind die nächsten jahre
spielen wird und trotzdem eigenen traum
einfliegen kann vielleicht denken sie
mal so
derzeit es ist richtig dass ihre
regierung dass diese regierung alle
menschen im leistungsbezug ungeachtet
ihrer herkunft mit dem sofort zuschlags
und einmal zahlungs gesetz bedenkt und
erlauben sie mir mit nicht weniger als
artikel 1 des grundgesetzes zu schließen
lieber fdp würde passen die auf die
würde des menschen ist unantastbar
da steht nicht die würde der deutschen
staatsbürger industrieland haft das gilt
auch für jene die mal deutsche
staatsbürger werden können mit der
aufnahme der asylsuchenden in dieses
gesetz sagen wir ganz klar wir sehen
euch und wir unterstützen euch und genau
das ist der geist dieser koalition
vielen dank
wir schauen uns garantie für die spd
gesprochen hier auch nochmal den sofort
zuschlag von 20 euro pro monat
verteidigt und auch diese sofort
zuschlag soll ja nur eine überbrückung
sein bis dann die kindergrundsicherung
bekommen detlef seif spricht jetzt für
die unionsfraktion
präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen das
ist unfassbar mit welcher
gefühlskälte sie vorhin gegenüber
ukrainischen flüchtlingen gesprochen
haben unfassbar
denn
wir müssen doch sehen wir haben es hier
mit einem unermesslichen leids zu tun
welches der russische angriffskrieg den
menschen in der ukraine zugefügt hat und
es deshalb ist es richtig dass wir hier
unbürokratisch sagen es werden
leistungen nach sgb 2 sgb 12 gewährt das
ist richtig und das ist ein wirklich
starkes signal richtung ukraine und
richtung der mensch
aber die ampel koalition geht wenn man
den text sich anguckt weit über das
hinaus was die
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz beschlossen
hat so sollen die leistungen nicht nur
bei den ukrainischen flüchtlingen
erfolgen sondern also hat das abstract
ausgedrückt auf alle anwendungsfälle der
massenzustrom richtlinie und da muss der
eindruck entstehen sie wollen flecker
einschlagen für das asylrecht
insgesamt wir haben bisher hohe anreize
die unser system schafft aufgrund der
verfassungsrechtlichen grundlagen die
auch das bundesverfassungsgericht
definierten die asylbewerber leistung
sind im verhältnis zu anderen
eu-mitgliedsstaaten schon jetzt
exorbitant hoch und verursachen pull
effekt wir sollten alles unterlassen
dass wir das in zukunft in die falsche
richtung ring meine damen und herren
und der gesetzentwurf sieht auch neue
ausnahmetatbestände für die wohnsitz
regelung nach § 12a aufenthaltsgesetz
vor die wohnsitz regelung soll die
nachhaltige integration in die
lebensverhältnisse der bundesrepublik
deutschland fördern und auch eine
gleichmäßige verteilung unter den
bundesländern bislang ist das möglich
wenn eine
sozialversicherungsrechtliche tätigkeit
nachgewiesen wird der unterhalt
sichergestellt ist und auch bei
ausbildungen und beim studium ist das
möglich sie erweitern das jetzt offen
integrationskurs auf ein berufs
sprachkurs auf eine
qualifizierungsmaßnahme merken sie nicht
was sie tun sie entwerten vollkommen die
wohnsitz regel und das erhöht das risiko
der belastung für bundesländer und
einzelne kommunen
meine damen und herren und das gilt für
sie hören so gut zu in der krise soll
man helfen dieser verpflichtung sind wir
uns alle bewusst aber nutzen sie die
krise nicht um grundsätzliche dinge in
unserer rechtlichen struktur im
asylgesetz so zu verändern dass uns das
nachher auf die füße fällt das vorgehen
verdient deutliche kritik die unten
union unterstützt den vorliegenden
gesetzentwurf das werden wir in der
nachfolgenden getrennten abstimmung auch
deutlich machen aber wegen des
unbegrenzten rechtskreis wechsels und
auch wegen der wohnsitze auflage der
ausnahmetatbestände können wir dem
gesetzentwurf nicht zustimmen
vielen dank
ich schließe die aussprache und wir
kommen zur abstimmung die etwas
aufmerksamkeit erfordert bei mir und bei
ihnen die abstimmung über den von der
bundesregierung eingebrachten
gesetzentwurf zur regelung eine sofort
zu starkes für kinder und eine
einmalzahlung an erwachsene
leistungsberechtigte der sozialen
mindestsicherung aus anlass der vorbild
19 pandemie der ausschuss für arbeit und
soziales empfiehlt unter buchstabe a
seiner beschlussempfehlung auf
drucksache 17 68 den gesetzentwurf der
bundesregierung auf drucksache 14 11 in
der ausschuss fassung anzunehmen die
fraktion der cdu/csu hat nun aber
beantragt über den gesetzentwurf in der
ausschuss fassung getrennt abzustimmen
um zwar zum einen über folgende artikel
des gesetzentwurfes artikel 103 das
betrifft § 74 sgb 2 artikel 1b das
betrifft § 117 sgb fünf artikel 2 nummer
eins und drei das betritt § 150 a sgb 9
artikel 3 nummer vier das betrifft § 146
sgb zwölf artikel 401 es betrifft § 1
also bewerber leistungsgesetz artikel 4
nummer fünf das betrifft § 18
asylbewerberleistungsgesetz artikel 4a
nummer eins das betrifft § 12 absatz 1 2
und absatz 5 satz 1 nummer 1
aufenthaltsgesetz und artikel 8 das
betrifft § 61
bundesausbildungsförderungsgesetz und
zum anderen über den gesetzentwurf im
übrigen ich rufe sie zunächst auch die
soeben genannten artikel in der
ausschuss fassung ich bitte diejenigen
die diesen genannten artikeln des
gesetzentwurfs in der ausschuss fassung
zustimmen wollen um das handzeichen
wer stimmt dagegen
wer enthält sich
vielen dank dann sind diese genannten
artikel
angenommen und zwar mit den stimmen von
spd bündnis 90/die grünen und fdp
gegen die stimmen der cdu csu und fdp
bei enthaltung der fraktion die linke
jetzt rufe ich auch die übrigen teile
des gesetzentwurfs in der ausschuss
fassung ich bitte diejenigen die den
übrigen teilen des gesetzentwurfs in der
ausschuss fassung zustimmen wollen um
das handzeichen
vielen dank fürs dagegen
enthält sich
herzlichen dank bei enthaltung der
fraktion die linke und zustimmung durch
die übrigen fraktionen des hauses sind
die übrigen teile des gesetzentwurfes
angenommen alle teile des gesetzentwurfs
sind ampel ins zweiter beratung
angenommen dritte beratung und
schlussabstimmung ich bitte diejenigen
die dem gesetzentwurf zustimmen wollen
sich zu erheben
vielen dank wer stimmt dagegen
dankeschön wie enthält sich
vielen dank damit ist der gesetzentwurf
angenommen bei zustimmung durch die
fraktion der spd bündnis 90/die grünen
und fdp dagegen hat die fraktion der
cdu/csu bestimmt die afg und die linke
haben sich enthalten
wir kommen jetzt zur abstimmung über den
entschließungsantrag der fraktion der
cdu/csu auf drucksache 17 85 verstimmt
für die sich und in diesem
entschließungsantrag
erfordert die union unter anderen
maßnahmen zu ergreifen damit geflüchtete
aus der ukraine nicht in die
obdachlosigkeit kommen und zum beispiel
auch dass die geflüchteten aus dem
ukrainischen krieg gleichmäßig auf das
gesamte bundesgebiet verteilt werden wir
sitzen die abstellungen zu der
beschlussempfehlung des ausschusses für
arbeit aber dieser entschließungsantrag
wurde hier von den abgeordneten abgelegt
unter buchstabe b seiner
beschlussempfehlung die ablehnung des
antrags der fraktion die linke auf
drucksache 15 02 mit dem titel regelsatz
ehrlich berechnen sonderzahlungen
reichen nicht aus wer stimmt für diese
beschluss
wer stimmt dagegen
zeitungen
genannt die beschlussempfehlung ist
angenommen bei gegenstimmen durch die
fraktion die linke alle anderen haben
zugestimmt sie empfiehlt der ausschuss
unter buchstabe c seiner
beschlussempfehlung die ablehnung des
antrags der fraktion die linke auch
drucksache 15 04 mit dem titel kinder
sofort zug schlag armutsfest gestalten
wer stimmt für diese beschlussempfehlung
wer ist dagegen er enthält sich vielen
dank die beschlussempfehlung ist
angenommen bei zustimmungen durch spd
bündnis 90 die grünen fdp und cdu csu
fraktion dagegen hat die fraktion die
linke gestimmt die fdp fraktion hat sich
enthalten so also das bedeutet beide
anträge der linken wurden hier auch dann
abgelehnt einerseits ging es da um den
regelsatz in der grundsicherung der
sollte nach auffassung der linken für
alleinstehende erwachsene angehoben
werden auf 8 auf 6 187 euro und in den
zweiten tag ging es um die erhöhung des
sofort zuschlags der auch hier
diskutiert wurde auf 100 euro monatlich